welcome everyone and thank you so much
for joining us for the yale development
dialogues a series convening economists
historians and policy makers to discuss
some of the most pressing issues
confronting developing countries i'm
katherine chaney i'm a senior reporter
at devex and i'll be your moderator
today as we ask the big question is it
time to reimagine sustainable
development
so as many of you know the 70th the 76th
session of the united nations general
assembly opens today and leaders from
around the world will be meeting
virtually and in person to discuss
progress on the sustainable development
goals
so as a reporter focused on technology
and innovation in global health and
international development i often refer
to the sdgs really as a way to capture
the issues that i cover
at devx our motto and mission is do good
do it well and we cover what is really a
global development industry
i see journalism as a way to highlight
what is working and what isn't when it
comes to making progress on the sdgs
spreading the best ideas and holding the
sector accountable which i think will be
critical in making progress on these
ambitious goals
but today we actually ask do these goals
make sense are they the best way to
to set ambitions to measure progress to
hold the world to account
for those who are less familiar and i'll
just give a little bit of background
before our panelists expand on this
the sdgs are a list of 17 interlinked
global goals they were adopted by the
united nations member states in 2015 and
they focus on everything from tackling
poverty and inequality to improving
health and education
issues like water sanitation clean
energy climate action industry and
infrastructure decent work peace justice
and strong institutions and finally goal
17 partnerships to achieve all these
schools there are specific targets for
each goal and indicators to measure
progress with this deadline of 2030.
the sdgs serve really as a blueprint for
how to solve the world's greatest
challenges but they're also the subject
of intense debate and i actually think
the cobin 19 pandemic among other things
has led more people to ask
how realistic are the sdgs do they
measure the right things and how can
they really hold up in the face of
prices like coping 19 and climate change
so today we're joined by several experts
on the issue i'm excited to hear from
them on exactly how we should reimagine
sustainable development
i'll go ahead and introduce them
stefan derkon is professor of economic
policy at the blavatnik school of
government and the economics department
at the university of oxford he's also
policy advisor to dominic robb the uk's
secretary of state for foreign
commonwealth and development affairs and
first secretary of state
between 2011 and 2017 he was the chief
economist of the department of
international development uh where rory
stewart was as well you'll hear about
him in a moment we're also joined by
shanta devarajan he's professor of the
practice of development at georgetown
university's edmond a walsh school of
foreign service and his previous
positions include senior director for
development economics and former acting
chief economist of the world bank group
he was a director of the world
development report 2004 making services
work for poor people and i'm sure he'll
draw on some of those insights
and finally rory stewart one of the
three co-organizers of the all
development dialogues is a senior fellow
at yale jackson institute for global
affairs where he focuses on contemporary
politics and crisis and international
development and intervention in fragile
and conflict-affected states lately he's
been very busy with afghanistan as you
might imagine
he was previously the uk's secretary of
state for international development and
in that role he doubled the uk's
investment in climate and the
environment
and the three of these panelists have
worked very closely together over the
years and as one of the organizers of
the yell development dialogues rory has
really taken the lead on framing the
session and saying this is why we need
to have this conversation and this is
why now um so before i go to rory i just
want to note we really love to hear from
our audience we always have great
questions from you all so while i
definitely have some questions prepared
please throw your questions into the q a
function on zoom and i'll get to as many
as i can
but rory i do want to start with you
here um this big question is it time to
reimagine sustainable development this
really came from you and um you know i
think you picked the perfect people in
stefan and shanta to discuss this big
question so can you expand on why this
question why now um why is it so
critical we have this discussion today
i i think the first thing thank you all
very much for having me and i obviously
want to spend more time giving you all
time to speak rather than myself but i
think one thing as a an ex-politician
which is important to frame is the ways
in which things like the sdgs emerge
it isn't simply that very distinguished
development economists like chanter or
stefan sit down and try to think in the
most
clear-sighted logical way about the most
efficient research they've done on how
to
do development well
what in fact happens with the sdgs of
course is that it is primarily a
response to another set of goals called
the millennium development goals that
came about in 2000 and which by 2015
were looking a little bit tired so in
2015 there was another pump to get
everything going again this time with a
target of 2030
and underlying an enormous amount of
what's going on is a funny combination
of academic literature and research
right which is transforming these goals
so taking them from the eight goals with
the millennium development goals up to
17 and new things emerging if you dig
under the surface of it a lot of what's
happening the sdgs is a sort of critique
of the mdgs
so one big change is suddenly these
goals become universal
they relate not just to uh developing
countries they can relate to all the
countries in the world so the united
states united kingdom is supposed to be
signing up to pursue these the same
chronicles
much more emphasis on things like peace
building governance human rights much
more emphasis on the private sector much
more evidence on biodiversity on land
and sea
why did these changes happen in 2015
well because people obviously felt two
things there one of them is here are
things which are excluded that we care
about like biodiversity
second thing of course there is a
political pushback from people saying
this shouldn't simply be countries in
the north telling countries themselves
how to behave we should all
be trying to pursue these goals
so become more universal become more
comprehensive
also become far more ambitious suddenly
there is a commitment not to halving
things like poverty and hunger there's
commitments to getting to zero on these
things
and new forms of measurement come in to
try to guess how effective they are
and i as a working politician found this
absolutely central to what i was doing
so i would turn up at the u.n general
assembly i did a big session as the
secretary of state on the sustainable
development goals gave a speech on it a
whole series of different events un
general assembly around them
and we all talked solemnly about those
things within them which we liked for me
as a as a politician obviously i was
particularly excited at the emphasis on
climate and biodiversity so i put huge
emphasis on that when i was from other
people i'm very interested in the shift
just from talking about education
talking about the quality of education
right other people extremely excited
that really it allows them to get into
issues like governance human rights
in a much more direct way
but somewhere in the background are
you know professor deveracion and
professor der khan sitting there looking
at this and saying out of all this mess
of all these things generated by
politicians by citizens by lobby groups
by ngos all of whom are feeding into
this process
what is getting lost what's been
excluded from this
right have we lost sight for example as
stefan might say uh on a focus on
poverty or have we lost sight on a focus
on economic growth or have we lost sight
on a focus of actually what works and
what doesn't work
because i think and it's on this that
i'm gonna hand over to the other
panelists i think somewhere within this
of course the great
fundamental point which is that autumn
flies can you don't have a moral
obligation do what you can't do
and therefore the fundamental question
of what works and what doesn't work is
somehow concealed in a series of
incredibly idealistic statements about
how we would like the world to be i'm
not that high-handed
thank you rory stefan i do want to bring
you into this and um first of all i know
you you as we critique the goals because
i do want to start with a a critique
because uh before we propose solutions
we need to understand the problem here
um i know one the goals are idealistic
as rory said um and would love for you
to expand on that and two in terms of
who they are relevant for you know rory
mentioned as a politician
from the uk going to the un general
assembly this was a useful blueprint it
served a purpose um and he was able to
use these goals as a framework but
perhaps not so relevant or useful for
everyone um so can you jump in on your
experience in terms of uh how the goals
have emerged and whether they make sense
well well thank you very much and
look what is there to dislike about the
sdgs you know we should only celebrate
them you know we have
zero poverty in there and zero hunger
poverty is still there there's g1 we
have learning for all we have economic
opportunities for all but also lots more
attention to planet to biodiversity
to to climate issues and so on you know
we we have there something quite
remarkable
kind of a vision for sweden in the whole
world you know a beautiful blueprint for
the world
and we got all the leaders in the world
to sign up for this what more actually
the job is done you know maybe we're
there and
this is a bit like well
i find it actually really
quite problematic okay and there's a
number of things that fundamentally get
lost
by celebrating and only celebrating and
the way we talk about the way they do it
so it's not that i'm against the sdgs i
think indeed it's about their relevance
and what we've actually lost so for me
maybe three points to make so the first
one is
you know rory mentioned a million
development goals there is the
millennium development goals they came
out of the millionaire millennium summit
and there was this famous photograph
it's probably the only time in the
global history that so many leaders in
the world were on the same photograph i
counted them 149 heads of states it was
signed by 189 leaders they signed up to
these mdgs and indeed rory said they
weren't perfect but they were the
beginning and then the sdgs were there
now i have a problem with that
photograph because i look at that and
yes i see there you know decent people i
see kofi annandar see tony blair see
bill clinton jacques iraq i may not
agree with all of them it's there you
see
me from china you see
putin there as well but actually you
start looking further
and then you say people that have been
put in front of the international
court of justice you have incredible
groups that came to power with massive
violence and preparation continue to
separate massive violence you have
terribly corrupt leaders there as well
and so on and now you ask yourself well
what's the point of signing up to the
sdgs or the mdgs what's the point
of course for those who are decent
leaders and you want growth and
development in their country of course
no country is perfect there is no sweden
in the world really in that kind of
idealized way
but for them it's just fine it's
business as usual it's what we try to do
and especially with the sdgs we can pick
and choose and so there's enough for us
we can do something it's good but it
doesn't make any difference now for the
countries where it really would matter
where poverty is terrible where economic
opportunities are dreadful where there's
no learning for all where there is
terrible attention to biodiversity
who cares
nobody needs to is held to account for
it you know calling them out on the sdgs
doesn't mean anything
so it's basically you know for the
countries for where it would matter most
it doesn't do anything now you could say
maybe
and maybe the second point is we should
just be conscious that it's probably
in the end this is really in the end for
rich countries
this is basically which countries to
have an accountability framework for
what they're doing
so indeed i know that definitely for the
mbgs sdgs where rory was
my boss in the secretary of state it
mattered for defeat at the time it
mattered you would look at him are we
doing what we're doing and so on so
maybe that's not so bad and actually we
can attest to that it focuses more on
outcomes and on progress but again for
whom is it relevant does it really
matter for those who are fundamentally
we should really care about and it leads
me to the final thing and that's
actually where it really gets
problematic for me
we see it on the u.n sitting out we have
the sdgs now it's going to cost you five
to seven trillion to achieve them and
every time again that's what we hear and
it's going to cost us that much as if
there's a supermarket for sdgs where we
can go and buy them and then achieve our
results in the world now there isn't
that supermarket in fact
um you know people making these
calculations in fact shanta um you may
want to defend yourself later did one of
the first calculations of how much it
was for the mdgs you know you disowned
it you know you have made the original
sin there and you've clearly put it
aside now and you've confessed your sins
but it's fine but you know you get this
impression that that's what you can do
and actually if we go back to the
countries where it should matter most
it's not money that's the problem it's
actually fundamentally you know groups
that are in power economic and political
deals that are entirely focused on rent
uh sharing for themselves you know
ashanta itself is quoted in a block to
say you know what would it cost to get
development in the drc
probably infinity because there's no
amount of money that you can spend at a
time on president kabila who wasn't
interested in growth in developing japan
he was only interested in computer games
and making a lot of money um you know
you can spend whatever you want it
doesn't make progress so what's the
relevance if we focus on the under wrong
countries and actually
even focusing just on development is
just something you can buy and it's just
about spending massive amounts of money
and that's all that counts i'll stop now
thank you stefan and perfect transition
to shanta and i will say um shanta i
know you have been quite upfront about
um
you know the challenge of putting a
price tag on this in fact um in
preparation for this conversation i read
a blog post you wrote shame on me why it
was wrong to cost the mdgs and here we
are doing the same for the sdgs despite
the challenges that stefan outlined so
can you expand on this a little bit when
it comes to the problems with sdgs um
why is this costing issue part of the
problem and perhaps you have more to add
to that
sure well thank you very much this is a
real pleasure and an honor to be in this
august group um
you know the the problem is actually if
we go back to the the millennium
development goals that both
uh rory and stephan uh mentioned
uh
they let's be honest they were
essentially an attempt
to raise
funds for foreign aid
um
and
basically the taxpayers and rich
countries were asking what are we what
are we paying for
all of this foreign aid and they came up
with a set of goals saying we're trying
to reduce child mortality and uh
increase uh primary enrollment and and
so on and in in a narrow sense
it worked it did raise foreign aid
since uh almost doubled foreign aid
during uh during that period
the problem is that
we got got got trapped into this
situation which stefan alluded to
thinking that oh that's all you took was
to get the foreign aid and then we would
be done
um
which was uh the uh the the point i was
trying to make in that in that blog post
but i think it's actually worse than
that
by focusing on the money
it takes away from what is the critical
component which is the accountability of
these governments to their own people
the problem is with if you if you say
here's here's 50 billion which was our
estimate for the mdgs and now it's 5
trillion was it
for the sdgs if you say well that's what
it's going to take then there's no
attempt for the heads of state to
actually tell their people oh we have to
make all these tough decisions
because the reason we are not making
progress on the sdgs is that then
they're not coming up with the money so
it gets governments off the hook
rather than actually being able to hold
them accountable for delivering on these
on these goals so i think the the uh
the
the focus on on the billions to
trillions is actually doing harm not
even that it's misguided not just that
it's misguided but let me say you know
on a positive note
the other thing is that we have learned
quite a bit about how
to make public spending effective
over the years so the the other problem
of course is that if you just have the
money it doesn't mean you're going to
get to these goals oh yeah a lot of
people have been doing very important
research on how to deliver on public
services
and there i would say that i'd like to
see more effort by governments to work
with communities there's quite a lot of
rigorous evidence now that actually
having communities monitor service
providers
can actually lead to better outcomes
like reduced child mortality
transparency of information is another
critical component when people know
what it is that they're supposed to get
and what it is they're actually getting
they mobilize and they start demanding
uh
demanding efforts and different and
let's be very frank different ways
of avoiding the political capture
of public finance
that's the problem we we have that's
stefan alluded to uh dr congo but we
have that problem everywhere including
to some extent in the united states um
of uh uh of of political capture now
there are
uh societies that have tried to get
around it including things like using
electronic transfer of uh social
protection payments that make it much
harder it doesn't eliminate it but it
makes it much harder for people to steal
it before it gets to
the intended beneficiary so we have a
big agenda here uh
let's
put the stage sdgs aside for a minute
and say how do we actually help improve
people's lives um and i think the agenda
is critical today because we also have
this covet crisis
and in the middle of the covet crisis
there's been a big push to increase
public spending on health and education
and social protection all for very good
reasons there's no question that you
need
more resources but if we spend it the
way we've been spending it in the past
we're not going to solve the covet
crisis
and and that crisis can blow up so i i
want to say let's
for the covet crisis itself let's use
what we've learned about increasing
effectiveness of public spending but
more generally for the sdgs let's drop
the discussion of trillions and let's
talk about effectiveness
thank you for that rory you want to jump
in yeah um so just to try to draw some
of these themes together so i i think
that the first thing is um somewhere
underlying the way in which we think
about not just development but almost
everything we do in our society
is we have an idea that somehow we have
a plan
at some sort of template
and if we just put enough money and
resources behind it we can sort it out
and we're particularly prone to this
idea when we're dealing with somebody
else's country
if you actually were charged with trying
to work with a
ex-co community in east kentucky you
might be a little bit more cautious
about thinking that you had some
universal template and plan and you were
just going to come in and if you put
enough money behind it the whole thing
will be sorted out
now
why is it we have this thought well it's
partly because we find it very difficult
politically and this is me speaking to
politician to
talk publicly about how difficult
development progress is
right the reality is of course that all
these programs involve partial failures
partial success
two steps forward one step back many
things don't work out
but we don't want to say that
what we want to say to the public is
we have a plan this is what we're going
to do this is this beautiful utopian
vision and if you just give us enough
money we'll get behind it and it's
particularly strange in the u.s context
because in the u.s context the marketing
so stefan talked about this idea about
development being like a supermarket
where you turn out and for a future and
you buy something
but the other dimension that stefan
maybe hasn't emphasized enough is the
marketing of the product in the
supermarket right what's above the shelf
and in the case of the us right from the
very beginning of the development
project under truman in the 1940s
the marketing has been about scaring the
american people
right yet she says when he's launching
point four a congressman says to him
we've got to scare the hell out of
people so it's all friend in terms of
communism
and an enormous amount that then follows
in terms of u.s development spend and of
course a lot of the drivers of this in
the 40s and 50s it's not european
countries it's the united states it's
arranged around this field
and we have the same phenomenon in
afghanistan recently around
counterterrorism
and it
is reinforced by a desire to have a
simple mission that you can explain to
the public
now what's the problem with that the
problem with that is that if you arrange
all your programs around the sort of
simple rather targeted mission which
markets well which sells well which as
shanta says is a good way of getting
people to reach into their pockets
as soon as that narrative begins to fray
there is a real risk that you're going
to abandon everything so obviously we've
just seen this with president biden in
afghanistan as soon as people are no
longer confident that there are
terrorists in afghanistan suddenly we're
not going to do any developments in
afghanistan right we have a thing over
the taliban we leave the country
entirely we're going to impose sanctions
and 40 million afghans end up being much
much worse off now
what is the alternative to that well to
loot back to where we began the
alternative would have to be to work out
how to produce something which is
neither
the extreme optimism of the sdgs and the
mdgs these sort of incredible utopian
statements about plans money nor
a total grim pessimistic we can't do
anything the whole world is impossible
but actually began to articulate
imaginatively and practically what it
would mean to work in different
countries in different contexts
what does it mean to work in rwanda
right which is a development success
story but has serious human rights
problems
what does it mean to work in ethiopia
which seemed to be a development success
story with serious human rights problems
and now looks very different to what it
looked like three years ago
what does it feel like to look work in
ghana which some development economists
don't want you to work in because it's
approaching middle income status and
it's no longer poor enough
what does it feel like to work in
pakistan where actually international
aid has very little leverage because
pakistan's too big its economy is too
large for pakistani politicians to want
to pay much attention to what any
outsider is saying
what does it feel like to work in south
sudan where salvakir
effectively is prepared to turn around
to the international community and say
do you want to cut off the aid i don't
mind because the people who are going to
suffer are just the people in the
refugee camps in the clinics and schools
i'm not interested in this project to
talk
so it's producing something which is
much more located in a place and a time
and is much more located in questions of
local power and politics in other words
to to quote my favorite um world bank
report
or produced four or five years ago the
entire framework that underlies this
which is that somewhere there is a best
practice and all we need to do is do
capacity building and find political
will is deeply deeply misleading
right
in the end
all of this comes down to local context
local power and local politics with a
capital p right over the others
thank you rory i mean i think that is so
well put and i'm typing as you go
because it just helps reframe how i look
at these issues as a reporter um you
know on the one hand um stefan has
mentioned that the sdgs are are a bit
like a blueprint for building sweden all
over the world and so it's hard to
critique that idealistic vision and yet
that is problematic um for the reasons
rory just outlined that um it really
isn't just that we have best practices
we can replicate globally every place is
different context matters um
and and so how do we reimagine that i
mean that's a big question we're tasked
with today
i i wonder shanta or stefan have you
been in rooms or perhaps been leading
these conversations yourselves in terms
of if this is not the right blueprint
moving forward what might a better plan
look like or is a global plan just
unrealistic and this has to be placed by
place i think the challenge there is
that doesn't really
bring the world together which is one of
the goals of the sdgs but thoughts for
what reimagining this actually might
look like or what conversations are
happening along those lines shanta do
you want to jump in first sure um i
no i i think what we we should be having
is a conversation about reimagining aid
because the real source of the problem
is we are still thinking of aid as a
financial transfer
and that's as as rory says when that
when that financial transfer is such a
small fraction of the economy as in
pakistan
they think that aid is not affected on
the other hand think about it if an idea
if if we generate an idea about
scholarships for getting girls into
school that actually spreads throughout
the country
that is an enormous contribution to
pakistan's economic development and it
could be an idea coming from outside
could be coming from yale's university
uh
for instance um
and we should be thinking if that's
where aid is really effective that's
what aid is needed the trouble is
there's really not a lot of money
associated with that idea
um so
the politicians
uh
when i have trouble going and explaining
that to the public that here we
we developed this idea that's going to
get girls into school in pakistan um
and that's our contribution that's our
age contribution so we really have to
switch around and if you you asked about
conversation this is this was almost my
my refrain at the world bank especially
when i was acting chief economist which
is that i wanted the president of the
world bank
whenever he gets on tv whenever he gives
his press statement not to start with
the amount of money they have left
let's start with
either start with how many girls have we
gotten into school or how many children
have we
prevented from malnutrition or at the
very least
what are the three or four ideas we have
generated that might get girls into
school or improve child nutrition
and they and say oh by the way
does some of this cost money and this is
how much money we're prepared to lend
but i still i i have failed i mean you
know you see even in the in the kovit
response every speech david malpass
gives starts with the 60
billion dollars or whatever that the
world bank has pledged you know
meanwhile there are africans dying of
covet
who are in some sense the clients of the
world bank uh and this 60 billion
doesn't mean much to them
uh at this point
it's such a great point and you know i
often think about the sdgs through the
lens of the role of journalism and i do
feel that's part of the problem and how
this narrative is covered as well is
journalists jump onto the numbers like
this much was committed but the key
questions are where did the money go and
and what actually resulted and you know
weeks after the press release when we
moved on to other stories not following
those commitments i think that's a
critical part of actually making
progress um i want to remind our
audience that we really want to hear
from you all with questions i see a few
starting to come in
but just go ahead and submit in the in
the q a
function and you can let me know if you
want your name to be shared or if you
prefer to be anonymous that's fine too
but we want to bring in your voices um
stephanie i want to go to you in terms
of uh you know could this be a turning
point um and if so
uh where do you hope things will lead
yeah i know so so let's picking up on
where where also rory was is that and i
do you know i do totally agree
with him of uh
of of these importance of starting from
place and time and and just even kathryn
you know i just wish
that journalists maybe should stop
publishing all these big announcements
and pleasures that everybody made seem
many times because
i definitely in the last 10 years i've
failed to stop my politicians and i'm
sorry including you to actually keem to
announce these big numbers all the time
and it seems to be
yes it is a problem uh
uh it's an endless set of announcements
um you know yesterday we had one billion
pledges of humanitarian aid for
afghanistan i don't know what it means
and i honestly don't know what it means
um
and so anyway but starting from that you
know trying to try to build this i think
the way i would like to think about and
and in the end because we are outsiders
and a lot of what we do is outsiders we
need to kind of always be conscious of
that so starting from a particular place
in time you know i would always start
from trying to understand uh and that's
what i would tell also our team is on
the ground to know understand the nature
of the commitment that in that country
exists for
things like sustainable growth and
development and poverty alleviation just
understand
where does the political elite want to
go where is it where does it want to go
now that's an important question because
we usually don't start with that we
usually think oh we're going to buy some
outcomes or do some outcomes now you
know spending money well is really
important but actually without that
understanding
we will forget properly to assess it
because i think there's always should be
two tests of anything that's happening
and it's
whether it's public spending in the
country or outside of bringing resources
in is that of course we should be keen
on making sure that the money is used
effectively you know that outcomes are
being generated and you know that's a
good thing about the sdg is at least it
talks about outcomes and it doesn't talk
about some kind of inputs
but at the same time ask yourself while
you do this is this the best way of
using your resources
to create at least a chance that the
underlying commitment to development in
the political space will start improving
and actually you know when they're
dealing with the case that rory says you
know if you do it in south sudan you you
have to ask yourself do i give an excuse
to solve akira or mashar to actually
ignoring entirely what we're doing i
remember being actually once as a
different person going to rebel-held
territory applauding that we were
spending so much on health education and
this guy said yes so i don't have to
care about these things
now that's a real issue now there's
other countries where ethiopia a decade
ago where you could say look they wanted
to try to do something yes maybe it
didn't succeed in the way we wanted it
but you can work with them in doing it
so you have a sense of that underlying
commitment and you lose you use your
resources not just to buy some outcomes
of course spend your money well but keep
on thinking am i nudging this country
forward in the line in terms of an
underlying commitment to development and
yeah that's probably where how i would
think about it
stefan i want to bring a question in
from our audience unless rory or shantae
wanted to respond to that otherwise
we're going to go to some questions from
the audience but rory did you want to
jump in
well let me come in very quickly i mean
i think the other thing to understand is
there's always the counterfactual so
this is the boring thing about
life is that
if one imagines in practice what would
really be involved in saying we're not
going i mean stefan's of course right i
mean there's not much point reinforcing
faith
obviously there's not much point trying
to help somebody who doesn't really want
you to help them
you know
not much point trying to believe that
giving money to silver care is going to
really lead to much
but the problem is
that that is very very difficult for us
to bear
because what would that really mean that
would effectively say well actually
basically all the money we're spending
in south sudan is a complete waste of
time so
what
are we not going to spend money on sales
and let me give an example that really
struck me most directly uh stefan's
point which is a really good one about
the elites isn't just true of the
national it's also true in many of these
countries that will be differences
between different local elites so
in afghanistan for example from 2001 to
2021
three million people in the bamiyan
province in central afghanistan were
extremely keen to work with the
international community they had good
local leaders
all the investment we put in went a very
long way there was a fantastic explosion
of high quality schools as our women
were going to university there was some
fantastic economic development projects
but of course we put almost no money
into that area why did we put no money
in there because that was the peaceful
area of afghanistan
instead the pressure was to pump all the
money into the insurgency areas in the
south the argument being
all these people are trying to kill us
and the reason they're trying to kill us
is because there's not enough economic
development they're all unemployed so if
we can just
generate some more economic activity in
kindergarten helmand then obviously
people won't join the taliban they'll
love the afghan government more and our
job will be done for us right now
imagine if i'd won my argument with
hillary clinton i tried you know
directly with sector clinton to make the
staff an argument i said why are we
wasting our money in southern
afghanistan because nothing you're doing
is sustainable but you build a bridge it
gets blown up
your development workers can't visit
these projects why don't we put the
money into the communities in the
central north that want to work with us
in fact into the centre of northern
saying to me what do i have to do do i
have to kill some american soldiers do i
have to let off a bomb and what do i
have to do to get some development
assistance
but of course you can also understand as
i tell the story exactly why it was
impossible for me to win that argument
and why it's almost unbearable for
people to say okay we're going to turn
our back on southern eastern afghanistan
because it's too complicated and we'll
put our money into the peaceful ones
thank you rory i'm glad we're zooming in
on afghanistan in particular in terms of
how
it highlights um some of the big
problems with with sustainable
development and with aid as shanta said
um i want to touch on a question we got
from the audience and i think it builds
on a point rory was making earlier um
rory you were talking about how
basically it's um
problems seem easier to solve when
they're far away and i see that all the
time in my reporting so
for example many donors in the u.s
supporting global education efforts and
increasingly with sdgs we're trying to
capture not just
butts in seats right attendance but
learning actual outcomes um shantae i
know this is something that you've um
written on as well that uh all this
money is spent for education and yet you
know kids at a certain age can't read
basic sentences um
and
and so the question just to sort of
recap what someone had sent in is
essentially if this is the problem
that you know
people closer to um these contexts are
better positioned to solve problems
right and i write about this a lot too
like local innovators are best
positioned to address say education
challenges in their country and yet
that's not where the money is that's
what shanta mentioned earlier right um
so i guess the question for you all is
how do we take steps um when it comes to
reimagining aid from top-down donor
countries giving money
with little oversight as to where that
money actually goes and how it results
in real outcomes two more as is often
described bottom-up locally developed
solutions
working to um
target
problems more more proximity in problem
solving and funding um of course the
challenge is that's not where really the
money lies um so in many of the contexts
where um we really need to make progress
on the sdgs if that's the useful
framework that's not necessarily where
the money exists to solve the problem so
ultimately it does come from far away so
thoughts on how we
change that paradigm
go ahead shanta
so let me suggest
yet another outrageous idea um
but it's actually being practiced in a
few places
you know rory mentioned you know salva
care is not interested in dealing with
donors
but the people of south sudan are
in need of some assistance
regardless of you know what the what the
leadership thinks right
and if we are essentially interested in
helping the people
why not
find a way
to get the aid to the people without
having to go through the government
the the the version of that is
cash transfers
universal basic transfers
get every and i i would do the the
thought experiment take the current
amount of a going to any country
and convert it into cash transfers that
goes to every citizen of the country
and ask
which of those two models is going to
generate
more development
and i think i said
this this sounds radical although it's
been proposed by many people over the
years uh but i think the usaid has now
introduced this as a benchmark you know
is to say whenever you do a project you
have to answer the question
would it be better to take this money
and give it give it out as a as a pure
cash transfer um simply as a as a
technical exercise but i suspect that in
real life
we would get a lot more development
we may we have a lot of unemployed
bureaucrats and
world bank officials but nevertheless uh
we can get
more development this way um and it may
be worth trying
i'm really glad you brought up cash
transfers and i want to stay on that
topic for a moment because when we talk
about
ideas to reimagine aids
you are absolutely right that
cash transfers when initially suggested
seems like a crazy idea to a lot of
people um and yet now is really becoming
a benchmark for donor agencies and i'll
throw out there just in terms of how
quickly this has happened
so i started
covering
tech and innovation and global
development
coming up on seven years ago
and one of the groups i wrote about was
give directly which was really a pioneer
in cash transfers and give directly had
this revolutionary idea to just give
people cash and see what they do with it
um and i think part of why
uh it didn't
initially take off or there was some
discomfort
in in the global development community
is
it leads people to ask why not cash
for all the different programs they're
implementing if cash becomes a benchmark
and what they are doing their
livelihoods
at development agencies at ngos
isn't performing better than just giving
people money um you know
that
may leave them out of a job so i think
it was quite disruptive quite
controversial um and i would just throw
out there as someone who covers second
innovation in this space i think part of
the challenge with reimagining aid is
there's a whole industry built up around
foreign aid global development and jobs
at stake and
uh you know people don't necessarily
want to
address the status quo if it's not in
their personal best interest perhaps i'm
being a little controversial here but i
know we want to generate some some real
dialogue and debate in this series um
and yet
you know
there's no better time than now it seems
given the crises we've mentioned to
really take a hard look at how this
industry works and how to make it work
better so sticking on cash transfers
um whether we want to talk about cash
transfers or other disruptive ideas and
why they haven't taken hold i think rory
and stuff didn't want to jump in on that
i mean questions has a big big subject
um i think
uh
it's true of course the shantae says
that there are many
development programs that are so useless
that you would be better dropping cash
out of a helicopter than bothering to do
it in the first place i mean many
projects where we spend hundreds of
millions and achieve absolutely nothing
that's for sure
um i think there is
a distinction to be made within cash
transfers i think cash transfers in the
humanitarian context makes an enormous
amount of sense makes a huge amount of
sense to say
rather than the united states shipping
over wheat from the united states you
give somebody some money and they go and
buy what they actually want to need
which might be a 10 why may something
else in the local market
i think cash transfers also make an
enormous amount of sense when it is a
larger crash transfer as a one-off
payment
if you were for example to give 250 to a
poor woman in a community in bangladesh
and it allowed her to buy some livestock
or
set up a small shop
there's good credible evidence that over
a year or two she might be able to
significantly improve her savings and
investment
however
uh i am much more skeptical about the
idea of
essentially trying to run other people's
social welfare systems
and there are two reasons for that right
so the third once humanitarian second is
trying to set up the small business the
third is basically saying here are
for example in pakistan
uh elderly people or disabled people and
we are simply going to fund the pakistan
government giving them 30 a month
what is the problem with that the first
problem is one of scale
the
economies of the developing world are
now roughly the same size as the
economies of the developed world
and even if we spend 0.7 percent by gdp
in the developing world on the
development uh on the developed world on
development well we'd only be
contributing 0.7 obviously
we couldn't begin to provide the kind of
cash required to run social welfare
systems but there's a more fundamental
problem
which is i think it would be politically
reckless it would actually destroy
public support for international
development programs over time
because you are effectively saying to a
grandmother in arkansas i'm going to
take 20 out of your pocket this month
and i'm going to put it directly in the
pocket of somebody else at the other end
of the world and this is not how people
envisage development
right people if they think about
development at all we're brought up to
think this is all about not giving
somebody a fish it's about teaching them
to fish
they thought about development in terms
of technical assistance ashanta said
bring ideas bring infrastructure events
doing productive investments that
generate much more than the dollar's
return for a dollar's investment
and you cannot sustain i think the idea
that the public will get itself into the
world as simply funding with its own
cash
social welfare systems in other people's
countries when they're struggling they
feel to fund social welfare programs in
their own countries
i i think it's very dangerous thing for
people to do even if
there was evidence that these approaches
were sustainable
smart point stephanie do you want to
jump in on that yeah not just just look
and and
having lived through what uh rory is
also describing in terms of you know the
the
the
it's uh it well i recognize it so look
you know when we talking what is most
effective as aids
i totally agree with santa i mean we
have a huge amount of evidence that it's
good for people
it's uh and it solves in sums as a
fundamental aid effectiveness problem i
recognize what rory describes i would
actually say give directly didn't quite
invent it i think diffid was doing this
for a long time beforehand um but that's
another matter um
but it is
but but i think a bigger problem i would
have with it is that while it solves a
problem for aid it doesn't solve
development and growth
and
now
it is possible
that we want to be
skeptical about
outside is able to influence development
and growth and therefore go for these
eight effectivenesses and that's maybe
the south sudan example is not a bad one
i probably am still more ambitious but
you want to be with aids you know i
don't want to be as gloomy as the
easterly and close and close or kind of
that vision so you want to try it so
so i'm very supportive i would also say
look you know
we haven't reached the end to also
trying out and doing better with with
cash transfers because rory mentioned
humanitarian
it's still a massive battle to get
humanitarian agencies to be willing to
use cash
and uh and it's amazing things you can
do um just you know we were recently
involved in bangladesh in a fascinating
thing with cash transfers where we
managed to get cash transfers in the
pockets of people five days before the
floods peaked during a flood crisis
because we could use forecast models on
the floods and we could basically manage
to give them cash before the crisis hit
so you know can do all kinds of things
but all these things are very much
outside us i'm still a strong believer
in the end development has to be
there has to be societal ownership of
development
and this is unfortunately then saying
well we we don't have an answer to this
i will need to still find something to
do what because we shouldn't forget and
comes back actually to a point that
shanta made earlier
a lot of
most of the resources in development
are actually the government's resources
in education
uh it's more than ninety percent of the
resources in lower in low and middle
equal countries that actually will be
the government's own resources
finding ways of getting them used well
for the benefit of people i think that's
still a big task of us of trying to see
can we help to unlock this cash
transfers will give us eight
effectiveness but it will not give us
development let alone growth
go ahead shanta you want to jump yeah so
this is a perfect segue because i wanted
to pick up on rory's very valid point
that if you go
with aid as cash transfers there's still
a drop in the bucket in terms of the
large countries and and so on but really
it this is comes back to the the
question of an idea
why not use cash transfers for the
government's own programs
i mean i did a calculation but the
colleagues of mine and i did a
calculation
about the oil-rich countries in africa
these are you know nigeria gabon angola
they're all very wealthy in terms of oil
and very poor in terms of development
and we did a
calculation that said suppose you took
20
of their oil revenues and handed it out
as cash transfers to equally to the
entire population
in in the low population countries like
gabon angola yeah to some extent angola
equatorial guinea
you could eliminate poverty you could
achieve goal one
tomorrow
with that that shows you the extent of
mis-spending of public resources
and then the question and i think rory
was alluding to this about the political
support for aid the real question is
of course development is not just about
people having money to spend on food and
clothing and things like that it's all
about public goods
and presumably that's why governments
exist to to
actually provide those public goods but
the truth is that in many countries many
low and middle income countries the
governments are not providing those
public goods they're stealing the money
right
and the reason for it is that in the
resource-rich countries
and in the a-dependent countries i might
add
the governments are not accountable
for their spending
because they're not coming from
taxpayers in those countries they're
coming from taxpayers in other countries
or oil consumers in in other countries
so you could think of a situation where
let's say a resource-rich country
hands over all the revenues as cash
transfers to the citizens
and then taxes them
to finance public goods
and we can show i mean i've been doing
some research on this recently can show
that that actually can lead to greater
accountability
by the governments than what you have
now which is really no accountability
go ahead rory
i i think this is all
fascinating i mean i i just
keep encouraging people to try to do
because stefan and i went through this
very painfully with different where
we found ourselves dealing with an
incredible buildup of particularly
conservative political opposition to the
zero point seven percent spending that
eventually led to the merging the
department and our cutting of our budget
and one of the things that uh is going
on one of the reasons people are not
aware that bifid was doing this stuff
before give directly is of course david
did it almost in secret
it's very very difficult to find very
much information about what was doing on
cash transfers on the web i went very
carefully through their
testimony parliamentary committees
through their strategic plans through
their statements
because at some
[Music]
levels subconsciously differed officials
must have sensed
that what they were doing was not
something that was going to be very
popular with the public and that they
would find very difficult to sell
now it's very easy for technocrats to
say well that's fine we've got the right
answer we've done the right research
this is the right thing to do in foolish
populist public they don't understand
what we're doing so we'll just keep
doing it and we'll just not tell you
about it
but it doesn't work right it blows up in
your face eventually right you need to
have projects that the public can relate
to and this too i think is the problem
with shunter's wonderful idea that we
give all the money and cash transfers to
people in gabon and the government of
gabon then taxes those people and puts
the money into the government and then
spends it out
i really doubt that you are going to be
able to say to the british taxpayer we
are going to take 10 billion pounds a
year off you
and the way we're going to spend it is
we're going to hand it out in cash to
all these people in gabon and then the
gabon government is going to tax our
cash
and put it back and this gabon president
who we might not approve of is then
going to have discretion over how to
spend it right so
the problem underlying the whole thing
is that
understandably
there's a culture that assumes that
if research economists come up with the
right model
we can somehow trick
the public and wealthy countries into
providing their money in order to follow
through on these schemes
but we can't
because we are failing to understand
the type of emotional empathetic
arguments that you would actually need
to make to the public to actually
believe in what's
happening
and that's also why certain kinds of
things which we stop doing we may need
to think about doing again so
it's extremely unfashionable for example
and it has been probably since the 1950s
for internationals to try to run high
quality institutions in other people's
countries it's possible to do that the
agriculture development network runs an
extremely good nursing school in
stanford right you can find examples of
doing this
and my instinct is that you could sell
to swedish voters swiss voters british
voters american voters we are running a
fantastic university here we're running
a fantastic hospital here
but it's profoundly offensive to
development economists it's profoundly
offensive to the academic world
and i one of the problems that i had as
a
politician is trying to get
people to be practical about what kind
of things you should do on the ground
that would actually excite a domestic
public
make them feel there's something to look
at something they can be proud of
something tangible that they can see
and i i think we we fool ourselves into
thinking that we can sell things that
are fundamentally unsellable
thank you rory well put and we just have
a few minutes left i can't believe it
this conversation is flown by but uh i
want to come back to each of you because
in terms of the why now of this
conversation uh one key reason in terms
of why to have this conversation now is
as i mentioned at the outset the un
general assembly so
it kicks off today there will be several
weeks um next week is kind of the key
week
but several weeks of big conversations
that sort of take the sdgs as a given
right like the sdgs as a starting point
and then talking about how have we done
how can we you know get to zero achieve
these goals by 2030 et cetera um i i
think it's really valuable to create
this space to challenge the whole notion
of the sdgs and and talk about uh
reimagining sustainable development and
reimagining aid so um thank you to rory
and our panelists for for sharing your
insights on this but before we close uh
given that the un general assembly is
now underway uh i would love to just go
back to each of you in here
if you could
gather all these leaders who are coming
together to discuss uh progress on the
goals uh with 2030 coming up and lots of
challenges posed to progress in fact
we've actually regressed on a lot of
these goals um over the course of the
pandemic
what would your key message be and um
perhaps we'll start with shanta and
stefan and then close with rory but
shantae can i start with you
okay
my key message to the leaders gathering
at the un general assembly
is actually derived from our
conversation here which is
if you want to achieve progress on the
sdgs
you have to be more accountable to your
own people
that's where you are failing and i'll be
very blunt about it now
as i was saying earlier i think the aid
establishment may have contributed to
this
lack of accountability or weakening of
accountability so we have to do our our
part as well but you know
here's um this is one criticism i have
of the sdgs is that we have 17 goals
but there's one goal
i think it's goal 16 which is the one on
governance
that is primordial
that's the goal that's going to generate
all the other goals but since it's
number 16 of 17 it's easy to say well
you know we'll focus on the other three
or four of the other other 17 and not
take seriously that one goal
and that's that's my message to all
these leaders yeah that is absolutely
cross-cutting and foundational agreed uh
stefan what about you what would your
message be
um my message would be
potentially it's a version of it
although i always struggle with the word
accountability because it also gets
interpreted in so many different ways
but my message to them would be is that
i probably would put them into groups
there are some countries in their own
way
probably
committed
to development to growth to actually
doing some of the longer term things and
i wish i could on behalf of say even my
department say look we'll support you in
that quest you know we allow you to
gamble on development and then i would
take that other group
there and say look you know
don't don't expect us to keep on just
trying to compensate for you because
actually for the reason that rory says
we can't
really permanently overcome the fact
that you not want to do this
but if you show commitment to doing some
of these things and maybe enchanters
works if you show accountability we will
be there and we will want to to to
support you
but it means also we can't just in
general say we'll write you a check
anyway we'll just be there as outsiders
you know eight is a bit like dancing the
tango if you're not both committed it's
going to go very very long
i love that analogy and uh surprisingly
had not heard it before but that's great
rory we'll close with you what would
your message be
um i think moderation
pragmatic messaging
the biggest danger in international
development and
is that we produce these utopian dreams
and in doing so we
are going to inevitably dissolution
ourselves alienate our public
destroy the credibility of our entire
project and run the risk that we lurch
from utopian dreams to sudden extreme
cutbacks abandonment
now the uk government has just brought
through in effect 70 80 cuts in many of
these fragile conflict affected states
in its programming because the way it
structured its budgets and it ended up
doing that in part because of this
ridiculous cycle
between fairy story and isolation
so unless we can get ourselves to
framing a moderate pragmatic way of
talking about development that it
embraces the fact that there will be
partial successes partial failures that
things on the ground are going to look
very messy
and that we're going to partner together
and listen together in the way that we
would with
difficult communities or challenged
communities in the united states or
europe communities that we would expect
to work with over 50 60 years and don't
have all the answers to
we're going to find ourselves in a
hysterical unsustainable situation we
need to keep faith and hope
and hope above all needs to be rooted in
realism
thank you rory it's a powerful way to
close uh we probably should just end it
at that but i did want to quickly say um
for those of you who are joining us for
the first time or unaware this is part
of a series and it's the eighth in the
series of the yell development dialogues
and i'm super grateful to moderate these
conversations bringing together insights
from history and economics and policy
it's really rare to have these kinds of
candid conversations on such critical
issues affecting all countries really um
and i can't think of a more timely
important topic as this one so thank you
again to rory and to shanta and to
stefan for taking the time to tackle
this big question about reimagining
sustainable development and aid
as as the un general assembly kicks off
and stay tuned for our upcoming
conversations tackling some other big
topics on health on climate uh and will
conclude uh this fall semester for those
of you following the academic year uh
we'll conclude the year with a
conversation on afghanistan so thank you
all and we'll see you next time